The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: I wanted to
talk a little bit about cork
partly because cork is
kind of interesting.
Cork has a structure that's
a little bit like one
of those honeycomb things.
What I'm going to do is I'm
just going to talk and go
through the slides.
I'm not going to write
the notes on the board.
There's only a few
pages of notes,
and it's in the Stellar site.
I'm not going to write notes for
this because it's just really
for fun.
This first slide starts off
with historical uses of cork.
Cork was used by the Romans.
They used it for the soles of
sandals, the same as we do.
And they used it
for stopping bottles
of wine, the same as we do.
But they didn't realize that
you could just use the cork.
They would take the cork,
put it in the wine bottle,
and then they would
use pitch which
is a tarry stuff from a tree.
They would use the pitch and
seal the bottle with the pitch.
In the 1600s, there were
some Benedictine monks
that realized that you
could just use the cork
and not use the pitch.
They were the ones who really
perfected the use of corks
in wine bottles for sealing it.
So what is cork?
Cork is the bark
of a tree called
Quercus suber, the cork oak.
Here's a piece of the cork bark.
All trees have a
layer of cork in them.
But the thing that's
different about Quercus suber
is that it's very
thick and the corks are
obtained from this thick layer.
Quercus suber is a
Mediterranean type of tree.
It grows, Portugal
is the main place
that exports cork, but also
places like Algeria, Spain.
You can grow it in California.
The cork is kind of
unusual because-- let
me scoot onto the next
slide-- it's kind of unusual.
So here's a little picture.
I went to Portugal when I
was a graduate student doing
this project.
Here's the cork tree here.
Here's the little
mini we rented.
Here's the cork
being harvested here.
Cork's unusual because you can
remove the bark from a cork oak
tree and it regrows.
So most trees if you did
this, you would kill the tree.
But cork doesn't get
killed by doing this.
What happens is
they plant trees.
You have to wait something like
10 or 15 years for the tree
to get big enough
to harvest the cork.
And then the first
harvest is poor quality
and they don't use that.
And then you have to wait
another 10 years or so
before you can actually
harvest the cork.
So you can imagine if a cork
orchard or forest gets chopped
down to build a skyscraper,
or apartment buildings,
or something, it's not an
economically feasible thing
to plant cork trees these days.
So when the trees
are cut down, they
don't tend to get
replanted at this point.
And there's a number of
artificial substitutes
for corks.
You've probably seen wine
bundles with foam plastic corks
in them too.
OK.
The reason it's
called Quercus suber
is that the cell walls in this
particular type of cork oak
are covered with a waxy
substance called "suberine."
That's where the Quercus
suber-- "Quercus" is "oak."
Every oak is Quercus something.
"Quercus alba" is white oak.
Quercus just means oak.
If we look at the
structure of the cork,
we can see that it's got
these different views
of the cork that are seen here.
This is a drawing by
Robert Hooke in the 1600s
from his book Micrographia.
He was the first person to
really draw cork like this.
You can see he drew sort
of boxy cells on this side.
And then, the other
perpendicular plane, the cells
have this structure here,
sort of more rounded.
And here's a little sketch
he's got of the cork tree.
Over here are SEM pictures.
These two planes here
correspond to this plane
in Hooke's drawing.
This plane here corresponds
to this plane here.
This over here is Hooke's
actual microscope.
I think the Royal Society
still has that microscope
that Hooke used in the 1600s.
Some of you know
that Hooke wrote
this book called Micrographia.
He got one of the
first microscopes.
He looked at a lot of
different materials,
and he drew these
beautiful drawings.
He wrote a page or two
about each of the drawings.
Harvard has a first
edition of Micrographia,
and I made a little video on it.
So I thought I'd show you the
video because the drawings are
beautiful.
But the url's on the slides, and
so you can watch it yourself.
There's more on
this and on how he
came to be so good at
making scientific apparatus,
how he came to do the
Micrographia book.
At the end of it,
there's a comparison
of a number of his
drawings with modern SEM
images of the same thing.
He had this very famous
picture where he draws a flea.
Don Galler, the person
who runs the SEM for me,
I had him put a flea in.
And he has essentially
the same kind of image.
The thing that's
spectacular is you
can see how much of the detail
that Hooke was able to capture
in his drawings.
There's some really
beautiful drawings.
OK.
So let's go back to cork.
Hooke was the first person to
use the word "cell" to describe
biological cells, and he
described the cell in cork.
That's the structure looking
at the SEM micrographs
and his optical micrographs.
These are just some
more higher resolution,
higher magnification, images.
One of the things
that you can see
is that the cork has these
little corrugations on the cell
walls.
See those little wrinkles?
All the cell walls have
those little wrinkles.
This plane here is the
perpendicular plane.
If you look down
into the cells, you
can see those blurry things.
Those are the corrugations
in the cell walls.
That's the structure.
Here's a schematic.
Here's the cork tree.
The cork is the layer
just beneath the bark.
This is a picture of how
the cells are oriented
relative to their radial,
and tangential, and axial
directions.
You can think of them
as roughly hexagonal.
They've got these
little corrugations.
This is a schematic
of an individual cell.
We measured the
dimensions of the cells,
and these are some
average dimensions here.
Typically, the cells are
tens of microns long,
and the cell wall is
about a micron thick.
Something like that.
OK?
One of the things
we're going to see
is that corrugated
structure gives rise
to some of the interesting
properties of cork.
If we load cork and just
do mechanical tests on it--
this is just a uniaxial
stress-strain curve.
You can see the
stress-strain curve looks
like all these other curves
we've seen for honeycombs.
There's a linear
elastic part here.
There's a stress plateau here.
And then there's a
densification part here.
Typically, the relative
density of cork is around 0.15.
Something like that.
It densifies at a strain of
something less than 0.85.
It's a stress-strain curve.
And when we did our
little project on cork,
we measured the properties
in the three directions
because in one direction,
it's roughly hexagonal cells.
That plane is isotropic.
The e1,e2 plane is isotropic.
This compares the
measured values
of the properties versus
what we calculated
from the honeycomb model.
And really, we just used
the sorts of equations
that we talked about in
class over the last couple
of lectures, apart from
loading in the x3 direction
because in the x3
direction, you've
got those corrugated walls.
And you have to take those
corrugations into account.
So there's another complication
that I'm not going to go into.
But there's a sort
of modification
you can do to account for that.
But you can see there's actually
pretty good agreement here
between the elastic
moduli that we measured
and what we calculated.
The compressive strengths down
here are not quite so good.
They're off by a factor
of two, more or less.
But they're in the right
ballpark for the cork.
So those are some
of the structures,
some of the properties.
One of the interesting
things about cork
is what it's used for.
The uses of cork really exploit
the mechanical properties.
Obviously, it's used for
stoppers for bottles.
I brought a champagne
cork along with me,
and I brought a couple of other
little pieces of cork here.
I'll pass those
around in a minute.
One of the things
to look at is just
the still wine cork, which
is the one on the right,
and the champagne cork,
which is the one on the left.
If you notice the
still wine cork
is just made of
one piece of cork
that's cored out from the bark.
And if you notice
these little channels.
These little channels here
are called "lenticels."
On the still wine
cork, they go this way.
And on the champagne
cork, they go that way.
They're oriented perpendicular.
It turns out that they are
normal to the isotropic plane
in the cork.
If you look at the
champagne cork,
this plane here is
the isotropic plane.
If you think of that
being put into a bottle,
I think part of the
reason they orient
it this way is
because it gives you
a uniform compression against
the neck of the bottle
and gives a nice seal.
So that's one of the
things about corks.
Another thing that's
interesting is
that cork has a Poisson's ratio
equal to zero if you load it
in that direction.
Let's see.
Did I not bring that picture?
Maybe I didn't
bring that picture.
Hang on a sec.
Nope.
I guess I didn't.
Sorry.
I thought I brought
a picture where
I had the deformation of
the cells when you load it
in that direction.
When you load it--
so say the cells
are corrugated this way on.
When you load it that way on,
it's like having a bellows
and folding up a bellows,
or unfolding a bellows.
So when you load it
that way on, there's
no expansion or
contraction this way on.
And so you get zero
Poisson's ratio.
And if you think of trying to
get the cork into the bottle,
it's rather convenient to
have zero Poisson's ratio
because you don't get
as much expansion.
As you're pushing
it into the bottle,
you don't get as much
expansion that way out,
pressing against it.
In fact, if you compare wine
corks with rubber stoppers,
this is a kind of
typical rubber stopper.
Wine corks are always
just cylinders.
In fact, even the
champagne corks
are cylinders when
they start off.
When they put it
into the bottle,
it's just a straight cylinder.
It gets deformed
like that from being
in the bottle for some time.
They have straight sides and
you can just squeeze them.
There's these funnel
things that wine makers
have for putting the
cork in the bottle.
You can just squeeze
them into the bottle top.
You can do that because
the Poisson's ratio is zero
and because the Young's
modulus and the bulk modulus
are both small.
But if you look at
a rubber stopper,
rubber stoppers always have
these tapered sides to them.
And that's because the Poisson's
ratio of the rubber is 0.5.
As you squeeze it in, it's
trying to move out this way.
You couldn't get the
stopper in unless it
had those tapered sides.
So that's sort of an
interesting thing about cork.
Let's see.
Another application
of cork is it's
used for gaskets for the
same sorts of reasons.
It's relatively compliant.
It takes up any slack
between two pieces that you
want to press together.
It's often used for
musical instruments
that come in pieces.
Things like
clarinets, there'll be
a piece of cork-- you
a clarinet player?
Yeah?
Yeah.
One of the interesting
things about the clarinet
is that, if you can
see here at the ends,
there's a piece of cork there.
And I think there's a
piece of cork down there.
And the other pieces
mate up with that.
The cork provides a seal.
And the way the cork is
cut, it's cut in such a way
that those lenticels go
radially out like this, which
means that the plane of isotropy
and the direction that's
got the zero Poisson's ratio
is that radial direction.
When you're squeezing, say,
the second part onto it,
the cork does not expand
circumferentially.
So as you're
squeezing it this way,
it doesn't expand that way.
It doesn't wrinkle or
anything on your other part.
They use the cork in a
particular orientation
for that reason, I think.
So it's used for gaskets
It's also used because it's
got a good friction property.
It's got a property that is
taken advantage of in things
like flooring and shoes.
Cork has a high friction
even if it gets wet.
Some sources of friction
are from adhesion,
from a surface effect.
Then if, say, the floor gets
wet, then you break that,
and it could be slippery.
But the source of
friction in cork
is from an energy
loss and dissipation
as you're deforming it.
Imagine you have a wheel here.
The wheel is rotating
on this cork floor.
And here, a piece of cork is
getting deformed as the wheel
rolls over it.
As it gets deformed, there's
some histeresis loop.
Cork has quite a lot
of damping in it.
There's quite a lot of energy
lost in that histeresis loop.
What that means is that's
characteristic of the cork
itself.
It's not a surface effect.
That means that if you use
it for floors or for shoes,
it doesn't lose that friction
and damping when it gets wet.
Here's some measurements we did
of the coefficient of friction
for cork versus doing
it dry and doing it
with a liquid, soapy surface.
You can see the soap
doesn't make any difference.
Cork is seen as a very
attractive material
for things like flooring.
It's actually not
a cheap material
to make your floors out of,
but it's an attractive material
for flooring.
Part of the reason
it's used for floors
and for the soles of shoes
is because of these friction
properties.
Another feature of
cork is that it's
got very small cells compared to
a lot of engineering polymers.
The cells are on the
order of tens of microns,
whereas many polymer
foams, the cells
are hundreds of
microns or millimeters.
We'll get into this
later, but this plot here
is really saying that
the thermal conductivity
of a cellular material depends,
in part, on the cell size.
The cell size for foam
plastics is in here.
And that for cork is down here.
Because it has a
smaller cell size,
it has a lower
thermal conductivity.
Cork was at one point
used to some extent
for thermal insulation.
If you go to Portugal,
where cork comes from,
there's hermit caves.
There were these old
hermit, religious people
who had holed up in a cave.
And they would line
the caves with cork
to try to make it a little more
insulated, a little more warm.
The other place you see this
is if you look at cigarettes,
you know cigarettes have that
little brown tip on the part
that touches your lips?
That's meant to look like cork.
And if you look, it
has little dots on it.
The little dots are
the little lenticels.
Apparently, they used cork
originally in cigarettes
as a sort of thermal insulation
between the cigarette
and your mouth.
So it was used for that too.
And then, one final thing.
Cork's also used, obviously,
for bulletin boards.
If you push a pin
into cork, then you
get this local deformation here.
Here's our pin.
And here's cells
locally deformed.
When you pull the
pin out, you'll
recover some of that deformation
because the deformation
is elastic.
So the hole will partly close.
So that's my little
spiel on cork.
And that's just because
it's interesting.
There's no test on cork
or anything like that.
OK.
So are we good with cork?
Any questions?
We're OK?
OK.
Let me scoot out of there.
Then the next part
of the course,
I wanted to talk about foams.
Let me just park the cork thing.
Let me pass these corks around.
So you can play with those too.
Oops.
There's little bits of cork.
There you go.
There's the champagne cork, the
rubber cork, some little cork
layers.
OK.
So the next part of the course,
I wanted to talk about foams.
And I want to talk about how we
model the mechanical behavior
of foams.
If we look at the
stress-strain curve for foams,
these are some examples
for foams made out
of different materials with
different characteristics.
The polyurethane
and the polyethylene
here are examples of
elastomeric foams, really.
This one here is an
open-celled foam.
This one's a closed-cell foam.
Polymethacrylamide is a
polymer that has a yield point.
Mullite is a ceramic.
You can see the
shapes of these curves
resemble the shapes that
we saw for the honeycombs.
Right?
They look exactly
the same, in fact.
And the mechanisms of
deformation in the foams
are very similar
to the honeycombs.
Even though the foams have a
much more complicated geometry,
we can use some of the
ideas from the honeycombs
to understand how
the foams behave.
So that was part of
the reason for doing
the honeycomb analysis.
Let me back up.
These curves here were
all in compression.
These curves here
were all in tension.
So again, these
ones in tension also
look like the curves
for the honeycombs.
Remember, in tension, we don't
get any elastic buckling.
So if the foam was
made of an elastomer,
we don't see any stress plateau.
If the foam is made of
material with a yield stress,
then we get a very
short yield plateau
because of a slight
geometrical difference
between pulling and
compressing the foam.
And if it's a brittle material,
then we just get fracturing.
There's going to be some
fracture toughness that's
going to characterize it.
We can look at the deformation
and the failure in these foams
and look at the mechanisms.
And what we're going to
do is model the mechanisms
and not worry too much
about the cell geometry.
So we're going to use
dimensional arguments here.
Here's a foam in compression.
It was compressed from
the top to the bottom.
And you can see this strut
that's circled in red.
This is unloaded.
And then, this is
after some load.
You can see this
has bent somewhat.
And then, you can see
this vertical strut here.
As the load gets larger, you
can see that strut's buckled.
In an elastomeric foam, you
get bending and buckling
just the same as we
did in the honeycomb.
Then here's a metal foam.
You form plastic hinges
in the metal foam.
So here's a cell wall here.
And it's a little bent to
start with at zero load.
But you can see it becomes more
bent in this image over here.
And here's a cell wall
that's more or less vertical.
And you can see
that wall buckles.
It's a plastic
buckling in this case.
There's a permanent
deformation there.
Here's a brittle foam.
And you can see cell walls
in this foam fracture.
So this region here is
equivalent to this region here.
That little glitch there is
the same as that little glitch
there.
You can see there's a
couple of cell walls here
that are fractured.
So we get fracture.
The idea is is
that the mechanisms
of deformation in
the foams parallel
those in the honeycombs.
OK?
All right.
So let me write some of
this stuff on the board.
We're going to
start off by talking
about open-celled foams,
so foams where there's
just solid in the edges,
but not in the faces
of the polyhedral cells.
Then we'll talk about
close-cell foams
where there's solid
in the faces, as well.
But the open-celled
ones are easier.
So we'll start with that.
In compression, we see
the same three regimes
as we did before
for the honeycombs.
There's a linear elastic
regime that corresponds
to bending of the cell walls.
There's a stress plateau.
And for elastomeric foams,
that corresponds to buckling.
For metal foams, that
corresponds to the formation
of plastic hinges.
And then, for ceramic
or brittle foams,
that corresponds to
brittle crushing, so
fracturing of the cell walls.
Then, if you load the
foam up to higher strains
and higher stresses, eventually
you get to densification.
And in tension, just
like the honeycombs,
for the elastomeric materials
there is no buckling.
We can get a stress
plateau from plastic hinges
if there's, say, a metal foam.
And for a brittle foam, we
would get a fracture toughness
and brittle fracture in tension.
So the idea is the mechanisms
of deformation and failure
just parallel what we've
seen in the honeycombs.
So we'll start off with the
linear elastic behavior.
And we'll start with
open-cell foams.
The initial linear
elasticity is due to bending
of the cell walls.
And if the thickness of the cell
edges relative to the length
is small, the bending
dominates the deformation.
But as the thickness to
length ratio increases,
then axial deformations
can become important too.
What we're going to do is
we're going to consider
dimensional arguments.
We're going to set the
dimensional arguments
up so that we replicate the
mechanisms of deformation
and failure.
But we don't worry too much
about the cell geometry.
What I'm going to start with
is considering a cubic cell.
And I've arranged the
cubic cell so that the cell
edges are staggered.
That's going to
give me the bending.
The edge length
is going to be L.
I'm going to say we have
a square cross-section,
t squared.
Here's our idealized model
here with a cubic cell.
All the members
have a length, l.
All of them have a square
cross-section, t squared.
That's an open-cell model.
We've got just solid on the
edges and nothing on the faces.
The idea is that if
I bend that, or if I
load that in compression, so I
apply, say, a stress out here
that puts forces
on those members
there, because I've
staggered these cell
walls with these
ones here, we're
going to get bending
in this cell edge here.
That bending is going
to be what we model.
I'm going to set this
up so that one thing is
proportional to something else.
These relationships are going to
be true regardless of the cell
geometry.
So I could have picked
a tetrakaidecahedra
if I wanted to, and I would have
had these same relationships.
I'm just picking a cubic
thing because it's easier
to think about.
So first of all, we look
at the relative density.
Remember, the relative
density is the volume fraction
of solid.
So it's the volume of the
solid over the total volume.
And that's going to go as t
squared l over l cubed, or just
t over l all squared.
You remember for the
honeycomb, the relative density
went linearly with t over l.
For the open-celled foam,
it goes as t over l squared.
The moment of
inertia in this case
is going to go as
t to the fourth.
Remember, we have a
square section, t squared.
So if it's bh cubed
over 12, b is t, h is t.
It's going as t to the fourth.
Then what I'm going
to say is the stress
is going to go as F over
an area length squared.
OK?
So if I look at my
little square thing here,
I look at having my force here.
Here we have a force f.
And it's acting
over an area that's
somehow related to l squared.
Right?
I don't know exactly
what that constant is,
and I'm going to not
try to calculate that.
But it goes as F over l squared.
Similarly, I can
write that the strain
is going to go as delta over l.
So the strain is going to go
as this bending deflection
here, that delta divided
by the height of the cell.
And that's also l.
Then I also know from
structural mechanics
that delta is going to go as
Fl cubed over E of the solid
and I.
Then I'm just going to put
all these things together
to get the modulus.
The modulus of the
foam is going to go
as the stress over the strain.
If I plug in what I have for the
stress, it's F over l squared.
If I plug in what I have for
the strain, it's delta over l.
So this is F over l and delta.
I'm going to replace
delta by Fl cubed over Es.
I'm going to use,
instead of I, I'm
going to use t to the fourth.
Then the F's are
going to cancel out.
I've got that the modulus
goes as the modulus
of the solid times t over
l to the fourth power.
Then I can put that in terms
of the relative density.
It's going to go as the
relative density squared.
So I can summarize
all of this by saying
that the Young's
modulus of the foam
is some constant C1,
I'm going to call it,
times the modulus
of the solid times
the relative density squared.
OK.
So this has the
same kind of form
as those equations we
had for the honeycombs.
Right?
There's a solid-cell
wall property.
The solid module's here.
For the honeycombs, I put
it in terms of t over l.
But the t over l was related
to the relative density.
How much solid you've
got is reflected
in the relative density.
And then, this
constant C1 wraps up
all the geometrical
constants that I've said,
one thing's
proportional to another,
and something else is
proportional to another.
C1 just wraps up all of those.
OK?
I'm just going to
say here C1 includes
all the geometrical constants.
We have to get C1
by looking at data.
If we look at data for
the Young's modulus,
we find that C1 is just
about equal to one.
People have also done more
sophisticated analyses
than this.
There's a group of
people who looked
at doing a full-scale,
structural analysis
of an open-celled
tetrakaidecahedral cell.
Remember, I said they
pack to fill space.
So you can look at a unit cell.
They also made their cells
such that the thickness
along the length of the
cell was not constant.
The thickness varied as
something called a "plateau
border."
If you have a foam that's
made by surface tension,
the edges will tend to
have these plateau borders.
And the thickness will vary
along the length of the edge.
So when they did all this
whole, complicated thing,
they could calculate
a value for C1.
They calculated 0.98.
So it's very close to 1.
I'll say analysis of
open-cell tetrakaidecahedron
cells with these plateau
borders give C1 equal to 0.98.
OK.
So that's the Young's modulus.
We can also look at
the shear modulus.
The shear modulus is also
going to be controlled
by bending of the cell walls.
And so the shear
modulus is just going
to be some other
constant times Es
times the relative
density squared, so
a similar kind of relationship.
It's just a different constant.
And if the foam's isotropic,
and if the Poisson's ratio
is a third, then
C2 is equal to 3/8.
Remember, if we have isotropy,
then the shear modulus
is equal to E over 2 1 plus nu.
And so you can get the C2 from
that if you say nu is a third.
Then we can also get
Poisson's ratio for the foam.
If the foam is isotropic, so
we'll say for an isotropic foam
here, nu is equal to
E over 2G minus 1.
That's just rearranging
this expression here.
And because E and G both
depend on the relative density
squared, they both
depend on Es squared,
that's all going to cancel out.
So this is going to be equal
to C1 over 2 C2 minus 1.
So that's going to
equal to a constant.
That constant's going to
be independent of whatever
material the foam is made
from and the relative density.
The constant just depends
on the cell geometry.
Remember, in honeycombs
we found the same thing.
The Poisson's ratio
for the honeycombs
only depended on
the cell geometry.
It didn't depend on
the solid properties.
the relative density.
So this is an exactly parallel
thing here for the foams.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have a
silly kind of question.
What is the difference between
foam and the honeycombs?
LORNA GIBSON: Oh.
The honeycombs have
cells in a plane,
and they're prismatic
in the third direction.
And the foams have
polyhedral cells.
You know what a
tetrakaidecahedron, a 3D,
polyhedral cell.
OK?
The honeycombs are prismatic.
And the foams have
polyhedral cells.
OK?
Are we good?
OK.
So there's a couple
more interesting things
about Poisson's ratio.
The same way we
can make honeycombs
with negative
Poisson's ratios, we
can also make foams with
negative Poisson's ratios.
They do it the same way as
for the honeycombs, really.
The honeycombs had
negative Poisson's ratios
if the cell walls looked like
this, this sort of arrangement.
So that sort of a thing.
We said that theta was
negative for the honeycombs.
And if you invert the
cell walls on a foam,
you also get negative
Poisson's ratios.
And the way they do that is
they take a thermoplastic foam,
and then, they load
it hydrostatically.
So they compress it in
all three directions.
And they smush the
cells in on each other.
And then, they heat
it up to a temperature
above the glass
transition temperature
while it's still smushed.
And then, they cool it down.
So they end up with that
structure frozen in.
And if they do that, they get
a negative Poisson's ratio.
I'll just say they
invert the cell angles
analogous to the honeycomb.
They load the foam
hydrostatically
and heat to a
temperature above Tg.
And then, they cool
and release it.
I have a photograph here of a
foam with a negative Poisson's
ratio.
You can see how the cells
have been smushed in.
It's the equivalent of the way
it's done for the honeycomb.
OK?
Are we good?
OK.
That's the linear elastic
moduli for open-celled foams.
The next thing I wanted to
do was closed-cell foams.
If we look at a
closed-cell foam,
we can idealize it in
this kind of a way here.
I've set it up so that
the edge thickness is
different from the
face thickness.
That's really representing the
fact that in foams, many foams
are made using a
liquid, and the foaming
is controlled by
surface tension.
Often, the surface tension
draws material into the edges
and away from the faces.
So the faces tend to be
thinner than the edges.
When we have deformation
of the closed-cell foam,
we've got bending of
the edges the same
as we did for the
open-celled foam.
But the faces can stretch.
So they can have an
axial stretching.
You can think of that as a
cell membrane stretching here.
So imagine if I either pull
on the foam or I compress it,
there's going to be some
axial load in the faces.
So when we analyze
them, we have to account
for both bending of the
edges and axial deformation
in the faces.
I'll just say we have edge
bending as in open-cell foams.
And we also get a
face stretching.
Another thing that can happen
in the closed-cell foams
is we can get
compression of the gas.
In an open-cell foam, the
gas can move from one cell
to the next.
But in a closed-cell
foam, the gas is trapped.
And as the volume
of the cell changes,
the gas gets compressed.
So we have another effect here.
So we'll say for polymer
foams, surface tension
tends to draw material to
the edges during processing.
We define two thicknesses,
one for the edge
and one for the face.
And then we apply a force
to this cubic structure.
And we can do an analysis
a little bit like what
we did for the open-cell foam.
Let me rub all this off.
OK.
I'm going to set
this up a little
bit differently than for
the open-celled foam.
We're going to do
a work argument.
We're going to look at
the external work done
by the force F going through
a deformation, delta.
And that's going to have to
equal the internal work done
by the edges bending and
by the faces stretching.
So let me set that up.
We're going to say the
external work done,
that's going to be
proportional to F times delta.
So delta is how much the whole
thing is going to deform.
Then, I've got internal work
from bending of the edges.
That internal work is going
to be proportional to F
over delta times delta squared.
I'm going to end up
with an expression
where everything's
in delta squared.
So I want to keep the delta
squared there for now.
And F over delta
is the stiffness.
That's going to go as E of the
solid times I over l cubed.
I is going to go
is Te to the fourth
here because it's
I of the edges.
I've also got internal work
from stretching of the faces.
That internal work
is going to be-- I'm
going to run into my
other equations here.
Let me put it down a little.
That's going to go as
the stress on the face
times the strain in the face
times the volume of the face.
Or I could write that,
instead of stress of the face,
I can put it in
terms of Hooke's law
and say it's E of
the solid times
the strain in the face squared
times the volume of the face.
And I can replace the strain
in the face by delta over l.
So it's delta over l squared.
And then, the volume
of the face is
going to be t of the
face times l squared.
Then I want to balance
the internal work
and the external work.
I can say F times
delta is going to equal
some constant I'm going
to call "alpha" times
E of the solid times t of
the edge to the fourth,
that's this guy up
here, over l cubed
times delta squared plus
some other constant I'm
going to call "beta" times E
of the solid times delta over l
squared tf l squared.
So far, I've got this in terms
of the force I'm applying.
But I want to get a modulus
of the foam out of this.
I want to relate this force
here to the modulus of the foam.
I can say the
modulus of the foam
is going to be related to
F over l squared, that's
the stress, divided by
the strain, delta over l.
I can write the force is
proportional to the modulus
times the deflection, delta,
and times the member length, l.
And then, I'm going to plug
that guy into this expression
up here.
And I'm going to get a
delta squared on the left.
And I'm going to get
delta squareds in each
of the right-hand terms.
And so I'm going to
cancel out the deltas.
If I put all that
together, I have
the modulus in the foam
times delta squared times l.
There's a delta here, and
there's a delta there.
That gives me delta squared.
And that's going to
equal alpha Es Te
to the fourth over l cubed
times delta squared plus beta
times Es times delta
squared tf, if I cancel out
one of those l squareds.
So here I can get
rid of the delta
squareds in all these terms.
And if I just divide
by l, I'm going
to have the modulus of the foam.
I get a term here that it goes
as alpha E of the solid times
t of the edge over l to the
fourth power plus beta times
E of the solid times tf over l.
Are we good?
OK.
And what I'd like to do
is instead of putting it
in terms of te and tf, I'd
like to put it in terms
of the relative density.
I'm going to look at two limits.
I'm going to say if we just
had open cells, if there were
no faces on the membranes,
if we just had open cells,
and we had a uniform t,
then the relative density
would go as t over l squared.
If I just had closed cells,
and I had a uniform t,
then the relative density just
goes linearly with t over l.
The relative density is the
volume fraction of solids.
It's the volume of the
solid over the total volume.
For a closed-cell
foam with a uniform t,
the volume of the solid is
going to be t times l squared.
And then, the volume
total is l cubed.
So it's t over l.
Now, I'm going to
define one more thing.
If I say that phi is
equal to the volume
fraction of the solid in the
edges, then I can say te over l
is some constant times
phi to the 1/2 times
the relative density to the 1/2.
And I can say tf over l is
equal to some other constant,
c prime, I'll call it, times
1 minus phi, that's how much
is in the faces, times
the relative density.
Then I could
combine all of this.
Can I put it in here?
Maybe I'll just
stick it down here.
Hang on.
OK.
Put it up here.
This is my final
expression here.
And this term here arises
from the edge bending.
This term here arises
from the face stretching.
So I think I should wait
a bit for you to catch up.
The idea is the
edges are bending.
The faces are stretching.
We're looking at the
work done by deforming
the edges and the
faces and equating that
to the work done by the
externally applied load, f.
OK?
That gives us two
terms, one that
accounts for the edge
bending, and one that accounts
for the face stretching.
To be comprehensive, we
want to take into account
the compression of
the gas, as well.
So there's one more term
I'm going to add on to that.
Typically the gas effect
is only significant
for elastomeric foams.
If you had a metal foam
or a ceramic foam that
was closed-cell, it wouldn't
really contribute much.
But just to be complete,
we'll go through this.
The idea here is
we say we've got
a cubic element of the foam.
Initially, it has a volume, v0.
If we apply a stress,
a uniaxial stress,
there's some change in
the volume of the foam.
So there's some volume,
v, after we compress it
by some strain, epsilon.
If we can figure out
what the volume is
relative to the
initial volume, we
can figure out how the
change of the amount of gas
goes from the initial state
to the compressed state.
Then we can use Boyle's law.
The idea is P1V1 equals to P2V2.
Then we can figure out,
using Boyle's law, what
the pressure must be.
And then, that
pressure is what's
contributing to the modulus.
When I do this, I'm going to
write down some equations that
just have the main results.
There's a whole
bunch of algebra just
to get from one to the other.
And I'm not going to
write them all down.
When I write the
equations, don't
panic if it's not obvious how
you get from one to the other.
In the notes that I'm
going to put online,
there's all the details of how
you get from one to the other.
The idea is that we start
with a cubic element of foam.
Initially, before it's
loaded, it has a volume V0.
Then we apply a uniaxial stress.
And we say the axial strain in
the direction of the stress,
I'm going to call epsilon.
Just from the geometry, you can
calculate the deformed volume.
So after you load
it, the volume is V.
And that volume on loading, V,
divided by the initial volume,
V0, you can show.
It's fairly straightforward.
It's 1 minus epsilon
times 1 minus 2 times
the Poisson's ratio of the foam.
Here, I'm taking compressive
strain as positive.
And if you do this
whole volume thing,
you'll get terms in epsilon
squared and epsilon cubed.
But because if it's
linear elastic,
epsilon is going to be small.
I'm going to ignore
the epsilon squared
and the epsilon cubed terms.
That's the total
volume of the foam
after and before
the compression.
And then, what I want is
the volume of the gas.
And the volume of
the gas is just
going to be the volume minus
the volume of the solid.
And I can get that by
just subtracting off
the relative density.
So Vg over Vg0.
Again, Vg0 is the volume
of the gas initially.
Vg is the volume of the gas
when I'm compressing it.
Remember, the relative
density is the volume fraction
of solids.
So I'm essentially subtracting
out the amount of solid
to get the amount of gas.
Then we can use Boyle's law.
Here, p is going
to be the pressure
after the strain and p0 is going
to be the initial pressure.
The building seems rather making
unhappy noises for some reason.
I'm not sure what
that's all about.
There'll be some initial
pressure in the gas
even before the strain, or
before the stress is applied.
That's p0.
So the pressure we need
to overcome is p minus p0.
Again, I'm missing
out a bunch of steps.
But using that expression
and this expression
and this expression,
you could find
that p prime is
equal to p0 times
epsilon times 1 minus 2 nu
divided by 1 minus epsilon 1
minus 2 nu minus the
relative density.
Then the contribution of
the gas to the modulus
you can get by just taking the
derivative of that pressure
with respect to the strain.
So remember, modulus
is stress over strain.
It's the same kind of idea.
So I'm going to call it E
star g for the contribution
from the gas.
So that's going to
dp prime d epsilon.
And that's going to equal
p0 times 1 minus 2 nu
over 1 minus the
relative density.
OK?
As I said, I'll scan the
pages that have the details
and put it online.
The final expression we get
combines all of these things.
The modulus of the foam
relative to the solid
is phi squared rho over rho
s squared plus 1 minus phi,
that's the amount of
material in the faces,
times the relative density and
then plus this gas compression
term.
Like I said, for most foams, the
gas compression is negligible.
So if p0 is equal to the
atmospheric pressure,
so about 0.1 megapascal,
then the gas term's
negligible, except
for elastomeric foams.
So that's the Young's modulus.
Then we can do a similar
thing for the shear modulus.
And the thing to
notice in shear is
that when you shear something,
there's no volume change.
So if you shear it and
there's no volume change,
there's no gas compression.
There's no pressure
built up because there's
no change in the volume.
So for the shear modulus, you
just have the first two terms.
And if the foam is isotropic
and you use a third,
then this constant here
is going to be 3/8.
And then, Poisson's
ratio is just
going to be a function of
the cell geometry, again.
And roughly, we could say it's
going to be around a third.
OK.
Are we good?
Let me wait a little bit.
So the idea is we're looking at
the deformation of the bending
in the cell edges, and
the stretching in the cell
faces, and the gas compression.
And we're accounting for
those different terms.
The next thing is to compare
these model equations
with some data.
And here's data for
Young's modulus.
Here, we're plotting the
relative Young's modulus,
so the modulus of the
foam divided by the solid
against the relative density.
Again, these are log-log scales.
On this plot, everything
with open symbols
is an open-cell foam, and
everything with filled symbols
is a closed-cell foam.
Here's our equation for the
open-celled foams, the simplest
thing that goes with
density squared.
And that's that
thick line there.
And you can see these
are all open-cell foams.
There's some more up here.
So that gives a reasonable
description of that data.
And then, these are two
lines for closed-cell foams
for different values of
phi, so different values
of the amount of
solid in the edges.
And you can see all
the filled symbols
are the closed-cell foams.
And they're in between this
line here and this line here,
basically.
So that gives a fairly
good description
for the modulus of
the foams considering
how crude this model is.
We're not trying to account
for the cell geometry.
We're just modeling
the mechanisms
of deformation and failure.
And then, here's a similar
plot for the shear modulus.
Here's for open-cells, 3/8 times
the relative density squared.
These are open-celled
foams down here.
These are closed-cell
foams up here.
If the amount of material
in the faces is small,
then you would
just get the shear
modulus varying with the
relative density squared.
Then here's data
for Poisson's ratio.
We don't really know
what the constant
is because we
don't know what all
these geometrical
parameters are.
But here's a value of a third.
And you can see there's
a lot of scatter here.
This is like less than 0.2.
This is more than 0.5.
And the scatter really
represents differences
in the cell geometry.
If the foams were,
say, anisotropic,
and the cells were
stretched in one direction,
then you would get different
values of the Poisson's ratios.
So that's the
Poisson's ratios there.
I'm thinking I'm
going to stop there
because that seems like
enough equations for today.
And then, next time we'll
start doing the stress plateau
and we'll figure out the
elastic collapse stress
from buckling and a
plastic collapse stress
from yielding, and
so on, and so on.
We'll finish doing the
modeling next time.
And we'll probably start doing
a little bit of other stuff
on foams next time.